[Music]
as hospitals around the world buckled
under the way to the pandemic
23 million children missed out on
routine vaccinations in 2020
putting them at risk from devastating
but preventable diseases
like measles polio and meningitis
the world health organization warns that
unless urgent action is taken
we risk trading one crisis for another
welcome to our kobe 19 special i'm
monica jones good to have you with us
but it's a bit like sitting between a
rock and a hard place isn't it
better avoid doctors waiting rooms and
clinics so you're not exposed to science
kobe 2
but at the same time miss out on
important health checks and treatment
now that's tricky for all ages but
especially risky for kids
polio is a life-threatening disease it's
caused by the polio virus which can
infect a person's spinal cord and cause
paralysis
a polio vaccine exists since the 1950s
measles is a highly contagious
infectious disease
and once a person is infected there is
no specific treatment available
most of those who die from measles are
less than five years old
a vaccine against measles was introduced
in the early 1960s
which means these and many other typical
and
cruel childhood illnesses can be
prevented
if only the coronavirus pandemic didn't
get in the way
it's a disease they never should have
gotten these infants in congo
are suffering from measles as covid19
has ravaged healthcare systems around
the world
millions of children have been deprived
of routine vaccinations
so the kovid 19 pandemic has set us back
a decade when it comes to the progress
reached by
childhood immunization the coverage rate
of
diphtheria tetanus and pertussis has
decreased
by 3 from 86 to 83
this means that we are missing out on
life-saving immunization
for 23 million kids and 70 million of
those
have not even been reached by one single
vaccine
around the world reduced access to
clinics
fear of catching covet 19 and challenges
reaching services due to lockdown
measures
have all contributed to a sharp decline
in children getting crucial vaccinations
experts warn that a further loosening of
pandemic restrictions
could lead to multiple outbreaks of
preventable illnesses
if countries are continuing to loosen
their public health and social measures
in spite of what we're saying
about covid that we're not past the
we're not past
the worst yet and vaccines are
continuing to roll out for covid so now
is not the time to release
public health and social measures but if
that's happening and as it's happening
we are going to see more and more
transmission
of the pathogens that are otherwise
vaccine preventable pathogens
the world health organization says
action is urgently needed
to ensure that the covid19 pandemic does
not deflect from the need to protect
children
from other deadly and avoidable diseases
and dr kate o'brien who we just heard in
that report
joins us now she's director of
immunization vaccines and biologicals at
the wh oh good to have you with us
so when we talk about uh 23 million
children
missing out on basic vaccines in 2020
due to the pandemic are we talking about
children primarily in developing in
poorer regions
or is this a problem across the globe
you know these um these children who
have missed out on vaccines are really
seen in all countries around the world
but they are predominantly found in some
of the regions
uh more than others so in particular in
the africa region
is one of the the areas that is
particularly hard hit as well as the
south
east asia region but i want to emphasize
that this is not just a problem of
four countries you know on the list of
the top 10 countries
that have unimmunized children
we find countries like brazil the
philippines and mexico
and this is partly attributable to the
size of the country
big countries have more opportunity for
unimmunized children
but also the missing out of vaccines and
a slippage in the uh in the program
coverage
and what consequences has uh this had so
far do we know
well in part for some of the diseases
that our
children are vaccinated against it's bit
too early to tell what the impact will
be
there are very considerable efforts
being made to try to catch these
children
up to try to find them again and give
them the vaccines that they missed
in the course of 2020. but we're also
starting to see
measles outbreaks in some countries and
measles as you know
is one of the most transmissible viruses
and one of the viruses that really can
harm a child's health even if they
survive the illness for years to come
afterwards
and how much you you say we're sort of
trying maybe to to catch up how much
leverage is there in terms of timing if
health services everywhere were to pull
their sleeves up and
and start doing routine vaccinations for
kids again can we catch up
we certainly can catch up and there are
a number of different ways that um
country programs catch up first of all
making sure that parents know
how important it is to bring their kids
back or initiate
vaccination even for those kids who who
didn't get the vaccines at the point
when they were you know the very
earliest
age as little babies the second is that
there are campaigns that can take place
we can strategize in a different way so
that that
vaccines can be given you know through a
special program
where parents and the whole community is
informed about the importance of
of coming to get kids vaccinated
especially those
who have missed out so we do have lots
of ways that the catch-up can happen
and what we saw in 2020 is that things
were really
pretty bad in march and april programs
really
fell backwards in terms of what they
were able to do but many countries made
a very special effort
and caught up a lot in the second half
of the year and especially
in october november december we have
seen a slip in the coverage
it wasn't as bad as it could have been
but we're definitely not out of the
woods yet by any stretch of the
imagination
right and of course now there's uh also
the question about vaccinating kids
against
kobe 19 there are pros and cons what do
you say
well we don't have any vaccines that are
authorized for use
in children below 12 years of age and we
only have two vaccines
that are authorized for use for
teenagers so we're still quite some
distance
from having the evidence that would
allow us to even understand
the safety the immunogenicity of the
covid vaccines in in young children
what's interesting is that young
children are not the group that are
most at risk of having a serious illness
with covid disease
certainly not the group that is at risk
of of hospitalization
or dying from covid and they curiously
unlike other uh respiratory germs they
don't seem to be
the group that is most transmitting the
covid virus
and so this is not the priority group at
this point the priority really has to be
in every country
health workers older people those with
underlying medical conditions that put
them at risk
of having a serious outcome so that's
really where the focus should be and
while we're in
still a situation where there's
insufficient supply around the world
and that supply is not being distributed
equitably
we really have to keep our focus on
those people who are
most at risk of serious outcomes and
those are not the children
all right dr kate o'brien from the who
thank you so much for your time and for
your assessment
thank you
now for more of your questions and that
means it's over
to derek
people keep saying we don't know about
possible long-term effects of vaccines
which just sounds like soft vaccine
skepticism what are your views
i think it's almost impossible to have a
fruitful conversation
about this topic because when someone
says
yeah but how do you know there won't be
problems down the road
um then that's sort of destined to turn
into a pointless
discussion as is really any discussion
that requires
predicting the future 100 um the problem
is
in life and in the pandemic we always
have to make decisions about the future
um based on data that we've collected in
the past
we have to choose our next moves based
on what that data
appears to tell us it's it's not a
perfect
infallible system by any means but
it's the best one we have when it comes
to decisions like
whether or not to get vaccinated so
so here's what the current data says
about
vaccines in general and covet vaccines
in particular
both the cdc and the who emphasize
that the chances that vaccines could
cause
long-term health problems are extremely
low
because past experience with many
many different candidates for a wide
range of diseases
overwhelmingly shows that when side
effects do crop up and they do
they nearly always do so within a few
days
or weeks of vaccination the biggest
vaccine drive in history though began
many months ago and and hundreds of
millions of coveted 19 doses
have since been administered worldwide
the rollouts are being tracked with an
eagle eye
authorities have detected a few possible
serious vaccine side effects in some
very rare cases but but nothing
that indicates any wider trends
on the other hand we have an absolute
mountain of data
on the potentially devastating long-term
side effects that getting covet 19 can
cause
being able to prevent them effectively
is a huge advantage so with the evidence
saying the advantage
so massively outweighs any known risk
why wouldn't i want to get vaccinated i
don't have to predict the future
to choose that the data says it just
makes sense
[Music]
and before we let you go party only with
pcr tests or
a vaccination certificate only then are
you
allowed on the dance floor in austria
the new restrictions are a reaction to
more and more infected people among
young people the delta variant is
causing a surge in infections
nightclubs in austria no longer accept
antigen tests however
partying itself is not being banned
that's all for this edition of kobit 19
special thanks for watching stay safe
[Music]
you